We've seen a few examples, measuring the time of execution
of toy programs of a loop that does nothing.
What we care about though, is the time of execution of our indexing code.
What I'm going to do next is write a program to be able to test the time of execution of indexing code.
To get a good test, we need to make a big index.
We need to fill up an index with lots and lots of words, and we could do that by hand.
That would take a lot of time and effort.
What I'm going to do instead is define a procedure that makes a big index.
What it does is take in a size, and then it's going to fill up an index with that number of words.
To fill up the index with that number of keywords, we need to generate different words.
What I've done is create a variable called "letters" that initially is all a's.
As we go through the loop, we go through the loop size number of times.
We keep making a new string. We add that string to the index.
I'll explain what make_string does later.
We add that string to the index. Then we change the letters.
We're going to keep increasing the letter. Once we get to z, we wrap around.
For now it's not too important to understand everything in this code,
but I do want to walk through the code a little bit.
What this loop is doing is going through all the positions in the letters array.
We filled this up with 8 different elements.
We're going to go through those elements, starting from the last one and going backwards.
This range group goes from the length minus 1 to zero, stepping by -1.
We're going to check each letter.
If the letter is less than z, that means we can increase it.
We're going to increase it using this code here.
I'll talk soon about the code that turns letters into numbers,
but what this expression does is get the next letter.
If the letter was an 'a,' the result after this will be a 'b.'
We're going to replace the letter at that position in the letters list with the next letter.
If the letter is a 'z,' we don't want to go beyond the alphabet,
so instead we're going to set that letter to 'a,' and we're going to go back
through the loop to find the next letter.
Once we've found one less than z, we break. We only need to change one letter.
What the make_string procedure does--that we call here--is just turn that array into 1 string.
It's going through the elements of p, which is this list of letters that keeps changing,
and concatenating all those letters into one string.
The whole point of this is to allow us to easily make big indexes,
so we can run tests on different-sized indexes.
Let's try this in the Python shell.
First I'll show you what the result is when we use makebigindex.
We'll start with a fairly small one, so I'm passing in 3 as the size.
What makebigindex gives us is an index with three keywords--
"aaaaaaaa," "aaaaaaab," "aaaaaaac."
For each of them there's one URL, which is the name "fake."
If we pass in a bigger value, this will have an index with 100 keywords,
so we're going to pass in 100 as the size.
We get this big index, and you can see it's starting to change the second from the last letter
to make sure each word is a different word in the index.
What we want to do now is look at how the times of execution take for different size indexes.
Let's make a really big index.
What we're going to do is make an index of size 10,000.
Remember our concern is to time for lookups--that's the operation that's going to happen most frequently.
We're not timing the time to make the big index.
Let's see what the time is to do a lookup.
I'll time the execution of looking up in index10000 the keyword,
and the word makes a difference.
First, let's try looking up the word "udacity," which sadly is not in our index.
We'd need a much bigger index to get up to Udacity.
The time of execution is shown here--it's 0.0008 seconds.
It's getting close to a millisecond but still quite fast.
Let's make a bigger index. This time we have 100,000 keywords.
It's going to take a little longer to make it, but we're not worrying about the time to make it now.
What we care about is the timeo to do a lookup.
[Approximately five minutes later...]
That took a long time. Let's see how many entries there are.
We can look at the very last element in our index,
and we can see we got to "aaaafryd," which I don't know how to pronounce.
Another way to see that, which we didn't talk about yet,
is we can actually index from the back using negative numbers.
If we use -1 as the index, that will give us the last entry in the list.
Now we'll try doing a timed execution. We're going to lookup in the 10,000-sized index.
We'll see the time is pretty similar to what it was before.
That time might vary a little bit. Let's try it once more. Again, it's just under a millisecond.
Now we'll try, instead of the 10,000 index, looking up in the 100,000 length index the same lookup.
And we see that the time is now 10 times that.
It's now about 8.6 milliseconds whereas before it was 0.9 milliseconds.
For consistency, let's try that again.
We'll note that these timings vary a little bit each time we do it.
There are lots of reasons why the time varies.
We're running lots of other things on the computer at the same time.
It's not the case that we have total control over the processor
and running exactly the same thing every time,
because all of the other programs might be doing other things.
The other reason the time can vary is where things are in memory.
Sometimes it's very quick to lookup a value in memory.
Sometimes it takes longer.
We're not going to talk about the details of that.
What matters is that the time is roughly the same each time we execute it.
It really depends on the size of the input.
In this case, it's the size of the input table.
When we increase the size of the table to have 100,000 entries,
it's about 10 times as slow as when we had 10,000 entries.
Now let's have a few quizzes to see if you can guess how these timings work.